it was a great really incisive  commentary from sophie corcoran who's  british she's on gbtv a conservative  channel in great britain she said quote  dear americans who mock us for mourning  our beloved queen she dedicated her  entire life to her duty and our country  even just two days before her death you  mourned a man who pointed a gun at a  pregnant woman by burning cities to the  ground we are not the same  harsh but fair what she's saying is  you're all laughing at us because you  think it is ridiculous that we hold the  queen sacred you hold criminals as  sacred you think it's ridiculous that we  have all this pomp and circumstance for  her royal majesty the queen you had pomp  and circumstance you had you had four  funerals that one of which was attended  by the soon-to-be president joe biden  for a criminal who resisted arrest and  died of some combination of police force  possibly of police force and a fentanyl  overdose because he had the toxic level  of drugs in his system